this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
well hello and welcome this evening my
name is Paul Marco I'm the executive
director of the Stanford center for
professional development and I want to
welcome you here to spend a few moments
with us for the Graduate Student
Orientation if you're here you're either
taking a graduate course or auditing a
graduate course how many of you are in
the master's degree or honors
cooperative category raise your hand one
many of you are joining us for the first
time as non degree option students or
NGO students how many RN do almost
everybody this is how typically students
begin with us how many of you are during
the course are interested to be here ok
well that gives us some simile of the
land this evening what I hope to do is
give you an introduction brief
background about Stanford University I'm
a graduate many years ago quite proud to
be a staff member now and helping run
the center I'll also present to you some
additional material about logistics how
you get engaged with SCPD how you
actually take the courses we'll do a
live demo hopefully that'll that'll come
off well live television is dangerous
television this is also being recorded
so if you ever you miss any subtleties
or detail or want to get to sleep faster
you can watch this and at your viewing
pleasure at your convenience so with
that I'm going to give you some
additional information about Stanford
University do I have any graduates in
the room besides Larry Fagan okay so you
can you can quote me and make sure I get
it right the Stanford University was
founded in honor of Leland and Jane
Stanford's only son who died of typhoid
fever getting educated in Italy he was
actually doing exploring archaeological
digs and to honor their only son they
founded the university and that they
said that the children of California
would be their children and they would
educate create an institution to offer a
practical education today Stanford has
grown from that vision to seven schools
that you see here only about 15,000 15
16 thousand
undergraduate and graduate students it's
a relatively small population and the
student to faculty ratio is quite good
here at Stanford University I would say
that the other thing that's key is the
research dollar volume associated with
those faculty and the sponsored projects
it's if you compare us against our peers
we're quite proud of the accomplishments
that our faculty have achieved I think
the other thing that as you look at
rankings in the School of Engineering
particularly our number of our
departments are rated number one and
many of them are in the top five or
certainly in the top ten and what what
makes Stanford unique now I think and as
you are in the working world are
considering is is interdisciplinary
initiatives we're really it's a focus on
a blending science biotech to create new
and interesting results that will have
an impact and so focus on human health
environment and energy international
affairs and the arts brief background of
Stanford University I'd also mentioned
one other thing when I was an
undergraduate er I played baseball and
Stanford has a unique ability to
actually get the best students and the
best athletes we have a hundred and one
and hopefully Counting NCAA
Championships second to none in the
United States of America go team and so
something that that actually is unique
and different Stanford the School of
Engineering is also a great place to be
you are all taking courses primarily
from the School of Engineering and met
perhaps in some other areas we really do
have one of the best school of
Engineering's in the country and by both
by rankings as well as by faculty
publications we are indeed in the heart
of the Silicon Valley I like to say that
every student who's here every faculty
member who's here and potentially every
staff member has a business plan in
their back pocket thinking about the
next Google Cisco the next Medtronic who
knows so certainly this is something to
which Stanford students faculty aspire
world-class research facilities we have
an unbelievable facility you're sitting
in the brand-new Hwang Engineering
Center just next door we have nano
facility which has just been completed
and to complete the Stanford School of
Engineering quad there'll be another
building that we're constructing which
will be the bio engineering facility
that's breaking ground now if you go out
if you're here during the day you'll
have pile drivers constructing that
facility as we speak
Stanford has a incredibly influential
alumni not as big as some universities
given the small student population but
many CEOs key thought leaders faculty
who are teaching at other universities
and also here as well and I would say
that from our perspective we have been
delivering education to industry to
bridge and foster that innovation for
over 40 years now as an organization and
for Stanford as has started the
initiative in 1954 so darn near sixty
years in terms of the amount of time
that Stanford's been thinking about
delivering education to industry and
we've been pioneering in a number of
different areas and I'll talk a little
bit about our Center you're here to talk
about the or to hear learn more about
the academic programs the professional
programs we also offer and I'll talk a
little bit about that but primarily the
academic programs has been the strength
of Stanford as many of you know a few of
you are taking non degree option courses
with an aspirational goal of becoming
master's degree or honors cooperative
students and the academic program has
been robust in a variety of different
areas for since 1969 and that has been I
think Stanford's legacy companies
support this because they realized that
you're getting cutting-edge education
from faculty who are who are doing
really interesting research and that's
that will then feed your ideas and your
thinking as you're on the job and they
believe for those that are funding you
believe that that will drive innovation
will make you a better employee and then
will benefit the company over time to
complement the Graduate portfolio twelve
years ago we created the professional
executive education programs and I've
highlighted one student
has actually worked in both sides of the
equation Breton was a mechanical
engineer he graduated from the National
University of Singapore came to the
valley worked at Sun Microsystems a
member company of ours and took a
master's degree in management science
and engineering he got some really good
training he went from an individual
engineering contributor to a group
manager and as he took the group manager
journey he realized that the master's
degree was useful but he needed more
practical application so he took not one
but two professional certificates with
us one in Stanford advanced project
management and then the other and
strategic decision a risk management
program and the reason I point to Brett
is because education today is a lifelong
journey and one of the things that we
hope as many of you begin the journey
that you may take that with us join us
we have lots of offerings not only the
graduate courses but as well
professional executive education and if
we don't come talk to me we'll figure
out what we can do on the graduate side
of the house it is a requirement that
your company belong as members many of
you may see your logos up here
there's a couple of different reasons
for that the most important of which is
to give us support in terms of exam
monitoring and exam integrity it's
really important you're taking a
graduate courses at Stanford University
and the companies and the HR support and
your your manager or your HR leaders
will provide the exam integrity and
we'll talk a little bit about that in a
moment it also is the case that many of
the companies support this because they
realize you're gonna get better and then
in turn that company will get better or
the group's the Graduate portfolio I'm
if you're here you probably know this
I'll run through this quickly we have
the non degree option category this is
where students can aggregate up to 18
units toward a master's degree if they
wish but this is how people engage can I
combine work life with family life and
as well take a course at Stanford
University some some of you may register
for one or more courses if you get
beyond three we'll come have a
conversation with you because it is
indeed
an intense experience as many of you
know it is Stanford level work many of
those non degree options students might
aggregate up to a certificate we have
many of them on our website you can find
the listings but this is a clear area of
interest for many of you who are out
there and thinking about engaging why it
gives you a discrete area of expertise
in a particular say computer
architecture or massive data mining sets
and then you can focus in that area and
improve your workability and you can
accomplish that typically in a year
maybe a year and a half something like
this depending upon the cycle and the
number of courses in the certificate if
you complete 18 units the typical path
is to think about and it apply to a
master's degree this is an honours
cooperative program of which you're a
part
what department great this is our single
largest department this year is our
largest department past CS in electrical
engineering the honors cooperative
program is the sort of ultimate ultimate
engagement with SCPD and with Stanford
University
it is a Stanford University degree you
have the benefit of working part-time
you have the full rights and privileges
of any Stanford student you can come at
some point if you wish and take the
entire run the table as it were for a
quarter to finish up or what not but
that you do have the full rights and
privileges of any Stanford student we
also have an audit program it's
relatively small offering the way we
like to characterize that if you just
like to watch the program you're not
sure if you're you can really do that we
allow for four auditors to watch that
you cannot engage with the faculty and
so on so this is a category that where
we have about a hundred students a year
so the SBPD educational path this is
gonna take a little bit of time so bear
with me it's a bit of an eye chart here
for students who want to register most
of the selections are in scpd's website
you'll notice HTTP is a little different
I'll talk about that in a moment
the registration occurs after the course
election and we accept payment for that
in order to give you access in some
cases
you need Department approval for non
degree options students you're approved
on a course-by-course basis as you go
that means that if you get in a
certificate program and in some cases
you get less than a B plus you'll be
denied access to the next course so
that's why I say it is serious business
in in a couple of department cases
that's the case most departments require
a B letter grade that doesn't mean you
get a c-minus and an A and an averages
to a B means a B letter grades so I want
to make sure this is serious business
we make if you're going to commit to a
Stanford course we want you to do well
and we need to make sure that you have
the right time and focus to do that
course videos are accessed through my
Stanford connection and the grades and
evaluations the audit does not get a
grade ndo and a CPA will be getting
their grades through access I'll talk a
little about that in a moment the way
that ndo and ACPs differ is by course
and by degree candidacy so once if
you're an HCP honors Cooperative Program
student then you can avail yourself of
many more courses in our that are listed
at the SCPD website everything that's in
access in in your degree area if you're
a non-degree option student you are
limited to the courses on scpd's website
I hope that's clear are there any
questions I'll have a allow a few
minutes for questions at the end but yes
if you have all the courses that SCPD
the questions are all of courses
available online
available on SPD's website and the
answer is if they're available online
they're on scpd's website yes there are
courses if you're a master's degree and
there's only one candidate here as far
as I know who you're able to take
courses across the entire portfolio and
you may have to come to campus to take
those but that's if when you're a
master's degree program you can you can
do that so the the first order of
business is you've gotten accepted
you're in your your program and next
week we start classes how do you get
access to the video so I'm going to give
you a quick demonstration of that so the
good news is that we have a reasonably
robust website many of you probably
recognize this once you're accepted to
the course you'll be you'll will ask
that you do my Stanford connection enter
your username and password so that's and
then you can log in I'm not going to do
this because I've got it prepped here
that will get you to a page something
like this computer I've got loaded last
year's video from spring computer
organization system CS 107 this will
drive a page you want to click on the
online videos component which I've
conveniently loaded and this will give
you the option to look at in reverse
order the various weeks of the course
from wreak week 1 to week 8 so we'll
give you Silverlight and Windows Media
Player assets and let's just say for
example that you want to watch one of
these videos which I have queued here
here's the video running this is exactly
what it looks like
fairly straightforward interface you
have the lectures on this side of the
entire quarter as they a granade
obviously not in advance and then you
have the ability to take notes I've
taken one note here so if I wanted to
jump back to that I would click on this
link it'll jump you back to the where
she's talking about logistics
so you have the ability to create notes
right down here by simply creating a
note and you can say you know cool stuff
and then you can submit it you can
decide to share it with others or don't
or don't share it's really up to you so
then that'll archive in your log so this
is a great way to review material if
there's something you're not sure about
if you want to share it with a TA for
example I don't understand this segment
this is a great opportunity so with that
I'm going to head back hopefully at that
point you will have you'll have reviewed
the videos and you're ready to go props
to the course website and look at that
so and get back to that now
so I do want to mention before I get off
that if you do have trouble and we
encourage you to test your system
wherever you are home at work
occasionally there's some domain
challenges that we face companies lock
you out please test it out and if you
have any problems we'll be happy to work
with you this this Stanford online that
Stanford edu and that number will get
you our support so please again the
emphasis tonight is if you have a
question or concern please let us know
as soon as possible we'll help you
troubleshoot that one one important note
you're here this evening
this calendar at scpd's website gives
you additional information about what's
going on on the court or important
deadlines and so on so you'll see even
here as a snapshot that we've entered a
key date for example is Friday October
14 in this particular quarter the
financial drop deadlines really
important to observe that date many of
you might sign up for three courses not
sure which one you want to take make
sure to drop before the drop deadline
there are very few exceptions and we
want you to make sure that you have a
good experience so pay attention to
deadlines please I'll come back to that
in a moment
they're often announcements on our
website giving you an idea if you're
taking a certificate program when the
signups are and so on this is relatively
straightforward we would sign up for our
list we'll get you some information we
hope it's not too onerous once you've
went taking the courses you need to make
sure to get to the course website most
of the time SCPD will have embedded a
link to the course website where most of
the material is archived sometimes
that's not oh that that's not the case
or we can't get the links fast enough
each course for the majority of courses
these days will have a course website
it's announced at the first lecture
generally speaking assignments and
deadlines will be listed there so you
come to my Stanford connection for the
video links you come to the course
website for all the materials for the
rest of the course and that's how
generally these courses operate again
important course deadlines and office
hours faculty members and TAS will
often arranged times for students at a
distance to engage with with you in
terms of the phone calls and so on so
observe those those details on the
course website for each offering
assignments there's some confusion about
assignments and I'm gonna try to clarify
that and maybe we'll take questions
afterwards but our hope is that you will
do this every time you'll submit the
assignment on time and by the deadline
two SCPD and or two your faculty and
teaching assistant it's really important
to submit it to us we will be your
advocates in the process of delivering
the homeworks and assignments to the
faculty however if it's shipped and I
sent the email and it went through and
data dined it didn't come to us we can't
help you so please work with us too so
we can be your advocates we'll date time
stamp this even if it's a digital email
and there are some courses which you
know this database challenge we have to
be able to receive that but just give us
information the homework was sent and
you'll see the additional information do
act quickly if there you sense there's a
problem with regard to homeworks this is
one area where we've had some challenges
because you you all get busy you're
traveling and so on and and and the
homeworks may not get there on time if
you work ahead plan for those deadlines
and let us help you be be advocates in
this situation exams so you've watched
the video you've completed your homework
and now it's exam time we will insist
that every single student who is taking
a course at a distance for graduate
credit provide SCPD an exam monitor
there's an exam monitor form and I'll
show you the link in a moment it's
really important that you provide us an
exam monitor and we've heard that well
what what if it's a take-home exam thank
you very much provide us an exam monitor
you'll be taking course next quarter and
you will be able to reference that
material in addition if I can't provide
enough arguments I will just tell you
that the Western Association of schools
and colleges has told us we need this so
help us by providing the information
identifying someone in your work or
office or if you're in an independent
contractor a local library or community
college that will provide us an exam
monitor because we will need it and we
will come after you and what you don't
want to do is get that the day before
the midterm which for Stanford on a
quarter basis is often two weeks into
the quarter in some cases so we're gonna
ask you move quickly in secure an exam
monitor as soon as you exit the room
well actually we'll have a reception for
you for those who are here but maybe
after certainly after that yes yeah the
question is can we come and take the
exam on the campus generally speaking we
would defer to the faculty into the
course requirements in some cases
faculty require it in other cases
faculty build an accommodation
understanding that students who are
working part-time and taking graduate
courses with SCPD can't do that either
way we want to get an exam monitor so
that we have coverage so that in the
event that you plan to take it on campus
but suddenly you're on a business trip
we have some we have some coverage
you're gonna have to scramble to get an
exam monitor thank you for for that
question
on our website and you'll see here
circled in red you'll see a way to look
at my course records for courses that
you've taken in the past as and and we
don't publish grades on our website
that's a domain for access just so you
all know and then you see forms and
transcripts and policies it's in this
area where you'll find the exam monitor
document that you can fill out okay very
important area so please please do that
there's been some notion about deadlines
you know work crept up on me I don't
know what happened and I'm just not able
to complete the assignment we are going
to ask again you work with us to meet
all the requirements that the faculty
set we are an administrative
organization and we when we when you
send us your data we get it to the
department they accept you would get it
back to you when we do the homeworks and
assignments we get the homeworks and
assignments and exams and we shuttle
back and forth we're the conduit by
which you're engaging with
Stanford departments in in the School of
Engineering and and also in medicine in
in the case of bioinformatics they set
the rules we are asked to try and
provide reinforcement for those rules
and so travel or workload is not a
reason for an exception that's really
needs to be clearly articulated the
faculty are operating a 10-week quarter
course typically and in that quarter
they are they're insisting that students
take stay here on Stanford's campus
staying on time with with the activities
here and it's important that you also
fall into that window that is to say if
you take an exam and week one and
suddenly industry students have a
different exam time the faculty member
have to create two exams so you're part
of the cohort that's happening here on
Stanford's campus and it's important to
honor the deadlines assume that you're
now a Stanford student taking the course
you just happen to not be sitting in the
room at the time that one note about
finals so there was a question here
about whether or not some faculty again
would require that you come to
Stanford's campus since you're all here
the presumption is that you're in the
area some people can't be and again
faculty will make that accommodation on
a case-by-case basis with regard to
requirements so please check your
website for the course as well as if you
have any questions either ask us or ask
the faculty and teaching team of course
evaluation so one question is I I need
to get reimbursed and I want to make
sure I get yes I'm sorry you had a
question reason the exam policy yet you
had a question about exams I've had a
little bit of there's been a little bit
of confusion of taking two classes so
far I there hadn't doesn't seem like
there was a clear policy I've heard from
I think I'd heard from one professor
that there's a 50-mile radius rule or
something like that
the professor's generally had been
accommodated before coming to campus
versus taking the exam
yes there's no hard and fast rule set by
the SUV or anything like that so that
really the question is what is is there
a hard hard and fast rule around maybe
finals or exams and some faculty have
been flexible that's the good news I
think there is every course will be
different most well can I say one is you
need an exam monitor I could definitely
say that the second thing I could say is
that work with your faculty identify the
deadlines and that and the requirements
around those exams each faculty will do
a little bit different by and large
there there's an understanding having
done this for 40 years that their
industry students there will be taking
the courses and there needs to be some
reasonable accommodation not for the
date but for how the exam is delivered
so course evaluations so many fact many
of you are paying out of your own pocket
again reimbursed by the company when you
get a grade you get reimbursed a couple
of important things the University
course evaluations will get you your
grades sooner so if you could complete
the end of quarter evaluations in access
then you'll be in much better shape to
get the grade faster otherwise you'll
have to wait and so we encourage you to
do that you will also have an SCPD
survey as well and two weeks into the
quarter we'd like to know how is it
going if there's any problems we can
encourage you to speak sooner rather
than later but we'll send you a survey a
relatively short survey should be five
seven minutes to complete and we're
trying to get a being a learning
organization and provide the best
possible service so we want to get
better so if we if you help us by
filling out that survey it'll be greatly
appreciated midterm feedback will again
on the course and the teaching team so
the first one is really about how's it
going and are you getting everything
that you need if not then we'll try to
do some remediation the second one is
okay so now you've taken this course for
some period of time how is it going are
you getting what you need from the
teaching team and from the quality of
the materials hopefully the answer is
yes in most of the cases it is but if
there are areas of improvement we'd like
to know that so that's a little bit
about course evaluations the Stanford
our code
this is really important your now as
graduate students at Stanford University
even though part time you're part of the
Stanford community and as such you have
to adhere to the rules of the honor code
I believe we can provide to you and
there is also listed on our website so
you'll see the link here the ability to
explore that what does that mean in
essence it means you're going to do the
right thing and you're going to do your
own work in essence and so we'd ask that
you follow those rules and guidelines
and and uphold the Stanford honor code
as Stanford students even if you're only
a Stanford student for one quarter
taking a non-degree option course I hope
that's clear and if not we can talk
offline about that when I tell you that
Stanford take seriously the Family
Education rights and Privacy Act or
FERPA and what that says here is that if
the company I'm going to summarize this
you but you can read probably faster
than I can if the company is paying we
will release that information and we
have there's a checkout form which will
allow us to do that sometimes the
company needs information to ensure that
the they can get reimbursed we do not
share this with with your information
with third parties so that's just so you
know that that's our commitment to you
and this is the notice student a student
chooses company pay we need to we need
your consent to release the information
to your company so so we'll ask it as
the checkout form you there's initials
you can do that and all students are
responsible for the tuition bill it's
not the company even though they may
reimburse you it really is your student
you're engaging with Stanford University
just to be clear I hope this is this is
clear this act is something that's
fairly important to us and so if you
need if there's any additional questions
there's a fairly detailed website and
information you can find if you're
interested so additional information and
resources first of all we're all here
this evening and we can ask questions at
any time we have a staff of about 48
people and we're here to provide the
help and support second on our website
there's a graduate student handbook and
orientation
video if you wish and also we have
course advisors many of whom will be
here this evening talking in various
subjects and so we ask that you send
those questions into the course advisors
link and there are different subjects
for those is so that you can ask
occasionally we have graduate students
who rotate out of the course advisors
and then we work with the departments
closely to get that information to you
so just you know how that works so
here's some what-if questions and you'll
see there's a fairly common theme what
if you have our logistical difficulties
getting started I can't see my video I
don't understand I don't know what time
when the homework is due and so on
please let us know we'll get to the
faculty and the teaching team my
colleagues Michelle Lucas is a program
manager for the graduated program as
well as Jonathan not man who's the
director of student client services
we're here to help jump on this and get
us information as fast as possible and
we'll try to react what if the course
isn't the best one you know you've
selected two or three and you're not
sure just watch the deadlines make sure
you're dropping at the right time so
that you can get reimbursed and so on
make sure that if you decide to take a
course again observing the deadlines
midterm finals homeworks assignments the
10-week quarter for those of you who are
starting moves very quickly and I think
especially if you've been on a semester
system and perhaps getting back into
school its moves fast how many of you
have had that experience take how about
taking a Stanford course and are
surprised at the pacing a couple of you
here yeah so it's you know get ready
it's it happens fast what if an
emergency arises there's some issue
please let us know in some limited
circumstances we may be able to make
some exceptions you know death in the
family so on emergency surgery this kind
of thing and those are the two
exceptions that I can tell you about for
having to drop or exit from a course or
something like this so other than that
work again is I got on business travel
I'm in this really big assignment yes
thank you very much and so are many
other people including our faculty who
travel all over the world and continue
to deliver quality education so work
travel is not annex
just want to make that absolutely clear
so with that I'd like to open up to
additional questions that I may have
missed dimensions and also with my
colleagues in the back of the room if
they if I if there's something that I
need they may help answer these
questions yes what are things of course
where your field degree is kind of a
final project yes do you have any
recommendations on teaming up together
other SCPD students for that course or
maybe right so so the question is for
the what happens if you have a
project-based course and most of the
grade is associated with a project-based
outcome and you have a number of
students who are in industry in various
companies with various demands well you
know many companies how many of you are
work on distributed teams and have
colleagues all over the world that need
to do work so I'm looking around and
probably most of you I'd say so how do
you solve that
I think the same dynamics that apply in
the workplace would apply in this
situation and I do think that there's a
little bit of commitment that needs to
be fairly articulated in advance I think
that most students who are taking
courses at graduate students at a
distance through our program are very
interested in getting solid grades so
they can continue so that's one
motivator
there's no guarantee that everyone we
participate at the same rate and at the
same pace and with the same intensity
but that's true in life as well so I
think generally speaking we've had very
good results of project-based courses
and with engagement with students and it
takes work it takes work as just as you
want minded with it with groups
distributed groups are around in
distributive projects yeah so the
questions are there any message boards I
think we we don't have we used to have a
discussion forum it wasn't used even
with this project group so many of them
evolved yahoogroups Google Gmail
whatever the technique is Drupal to book
sessions it's really up to you there
there's so many tools out there rather
than us prescribe tools we encourage you
to to figure out the best way to engage
as you might in any group
outside of outside of the Stanford yes
there's a question in the back requires
a team of two how how would you find a
second person if a project requires a
team of two how do you find the second
person well so in we do try to provide a
class list to the TAS they'll be a blast
if there was a project course the TAS
will coordinate that you'll know well in
advance and there may be a selection
either on campus or on on the students
at a distance who might engage so we
really defer to the TA and the specific
course er case I can't sort of give you
an example because I don't have one I
know many of you have taken courses with
Tom kosnik he does have a group and we
Michele Lucas has helped coordinate some
of those activities do conference calls
and so on so faculty understand if
there's a requirement like that they're
going to try to help figure that out
this is a follow-on question website
they didn't go you made your home look
into the word document format or PDF
format
yeah we'll take whatever questions when
you send a work assignment what what
should it be whatever what for whatever
format is easiest and most reliable you
know the nice thing about PDFs is that
if it's a large file then like a
PowerPoint and that's a presentation or
something then a PDF will shrink that
and send it along there may be some
other file format that that might be
useful the only thing is a that as I
mentioned that the database courses in
computer science sometimes we can't
accept that file for me because we don't
have the database the Oracle database
running the system yes question here two
questions quickly for if you're taking
that certificate can you skip a quarter
perhaps no the question is run
certificates and whether or not you can
skip the answer is you can and you we
generally recommend that and the
Department will also and we enforce this
they can change the rules at any time
I'm kidding you three years window is
first certificate and so we really want
to try to have that wrapped up so you
can skip by say a year if the cycle and
some of the cases that there's four
courses you have to take and you know
there may be a year cycle and you may
miss the entire year getting that fourth
course in or something like this so
generally speaking you need to complete
a certificate in three
- more - just the plus yeah so the
question is about Stanford grades and
again it made it buried depending upon
department but there's there's minuses
and pluses I can attest to that
yes so how the video system start so can
you ask questions oh yeah the question
is how I interact with other video
sessions this is the the video sessions
are asynchronous it's assumed that well
so we don't have live video streaming
from the classrooms we only capture and
archive and show those to you live the
teaching teams will be of make
themselves available to provide
questions and answers there is no
question you can ask currently in our
system to inquire there's not live
stream it's all archived and part of
that is because when we did a survey no
one watches live courses they actually
all watch the archived version or a
videotape version in the old days with
newer technologies coming or
experimenting with various ways to
explore interactivity into the classroom
but it's still then would require people
be ready to do it at the - to engage in
the class on the live basis and most
people are working when the courses are
delivered
generally speaking between 10:00 and
3:00 p.m. here it's - on Stanford's
campus so its interactivity is a nice
idea but in practical matters it's very
difficult to implement
yes question here so the question is on
discussion hours if it's a 5 to 7 p.m.
and you can actually get here I think
the the especially if it's a problem
session the the TAS and the faculty
would love it if you could come here and
ask the questions
SCPD does its best to capture problem
sessions as well as any burrs exams and
reviews to the extent possible and to
the extent that faculty tell us about
them we try to put those online so that
you have the benefit of that
so you're there seems to be a problem
you're talking about an issue with
regard to enrolling in a particular
discussion section and availability I
would say that mamala take that offline
I work directly with the faculty and
teaching team because that that should
be something that I think if you can get
here they would certainly welcome you to
be engaged there's another question here
so if you're a master's degree student
in the honors cooperative program you
have full rights and privileges no
problem in the non degree option student
category the non-aggression students
generally speaking do not come to campus
in fact you're by the policy not allowed
to come in Stanford's campus as a
non-degree option student unless the
faculty require or unless you can attend
the problem sessions and so on so
generally speaking non degree option
students don't have rights and
privileges for libraries we do have an
engineering library and if you happen to
be in the area and you can demonstrate
typically you're given an ID on a
quarter by quarter basis a number of
student number you couldn't provide that
to them and get access to the
engineering library and if there are
other libraries you'd like to get access
to what we happy to work with you on
that
the challenge with non degree option
students is that we actually have 561
enrollments right now and if every
non-degree option students showed up on
the Stanford campus we'd be in a little
bit of trouble with regard to space in
the classrooms so the non-degree option
student doesn't I don't have quite the
full rights and privileges that the
master's degree students do in and and
one of them is coming on the Stanford
campus I hope that's clear yeah so the
question is around exam monitors do you
need examine exam honors for every
course or is one sufficient actually we
think that the one is sufficient as long
as it's the right one it's not your
brother or your wife or your girlfriend
and or you know this kind of thing
we require that it be a manager or if
you're an independent you go to a local
community college and again this is a
goes to the honor code we expect as a
Stanford graduate student taking a
graduate course you're doing the right
thing
and part of that is making sure that you
have it can be one exam monitor
throughout your entire SCPD experience
and as long as that's the right person
doing the right thing we're good
yes follow-on question good question so
the question is really around exam
monitors and whether or not you need to
reappoint one if you're not agree option
students we don't know that you're
you're registered every quarter so we
ask that you you've provide that a data
check with that website if that person
is the default person or you need to
provide that name again then there
should be relatively simple but we ask
that for every quarter you do provide
that yes so the question really is
around if you're taking a non degree
option and you a granade certificate and
then you want it you take the GREs and
you apply how does that work so the
couple of dimensions to this question
first when you take non degree option
courses let's just say Electrical
Engineering you'll get credit in at
Stanford University for those 18 units
those are transferable to the electrical
engineering degree that you might be
interested in taking if however you take
10 units in management science and
engineering and you apply for electrical
engineering master's degree those units
may or may not be transferable into the
electrical engineering master's degree
so generally speaking the units that are
transferable or those in the discipline
in which you've taken them if that makes
any sense so if you take 10 units MS&E
and you apply to MS&E those units will
be transferable into the master's degree
so that's one dimension the second
dimension is that that you'll be getting
a grade at Stanford University at the
registrar's office for any graduate
course that you take that's also
potentially transferable to other
universities if they Alex
many you need to check University by the
university that made that that policy
may vary I hope that answers your
question
so each department you apply for a
master's degree with each department and
meet the requirements for each
department Philip for the master's
degree so for example in management
science they have details and
information about how you would apply
for that master's degree and that's
where you would have plot you would
apply for the master's degree ultimately
management science and engineering will
make the selection of whether or not
you're accepted to that degree area and
so you may need five letters of
recommendation added varies by
Department what the requirements are so
you need to look at the department's
website now I'll give you a clarity
about what you need to accomplish
including GREs and then you can if you
take a non degree option courses you
might be able to aggregate that if it's
in the same discipline I hope that helps
yes so the question is really around if
you have a preset travel you know it's
going to happen and it coincides with a
midterm or final you need to talk to the
faculty member in advance as you're
taking the course so that you can
resolve that faculty members will work
with you on a case by case basis to try
to resolve that they have the option of
saying sorry we can't accommodate your
request in which case then you know
there's not much that we as an
organization can do we have to honor
respect the policies that both the
department set as well as the the
faculty and their specific issues
however you know many faculty are
flexible and will accommodate industry
students because it's an important
component of Stanford's education
mission as we talked about earlier
question do you use archive I'm sorry to
ask that
oh how soon are the lectures great
question so how sooner the lecture video
lectures archive
generally speaking within one hour
of the class being completed and the
fact that the member puts down his or
her chalk or overhead or whatnot
it'll be available online in some cases
that may take the class may end at 6
p.m. and it's being taped in another
location on Stanford's campus it might
not be available until the following
morning when our team comes in to
archive it and so on or the tape needs
to be shuttled and so on and so forth so
it's not quite that way but it's pretty
close we can get it done in an hour and
in fact we can get it done in minutes
but we like to make sure that there's a
quality control that we have that
process we have in place if you want to
watch life at that time you cannot
because we don't the questions are
online we don't stream live so the
question is what is the difference
between access and scpd's website scpd's
website has a subset of school and
sharing offerings and we extend that to
non-degree option students so we have
all the courses it was an earlier
question about courses if it's on scpd's
website generally speaking it's online
in some rare cases we may offer a course
that you have to come to campus for but
that's very rare generally speaking the
offerings that we have on our website
will be online if you're a master's
degree student and honors co-operative
student you can then look at access to
determine what courses you might take
because you have the full rights and
privileges of a master's student which
includes selecting courses from across
the portfolio of offerings at Stanford
University not just the department but
at Stanford should I take it
it's my connection so your questions
really about how to access course
materials and course websites so many
Stanford University and the faculty have
many choices to develop their website
some in computer science develop their
own with really bright undergrad or
graduate students and that's sort of an
interesting experience Stanford
University generally speaking has a
system called course
of course work and so you that often
faculty leverage that existing research
on the campus to get get their website
what SCPD does in most cases is have the
video link and the course website link
embedded and connected so you can you
could you you should really should be
able to go into my Stanford connection
wash your videos and then have a link to
the course website that's sort of the
operating standard in the worst case in
the first lecture there may be another
course website link so you just that's
how you would access the materials for
the course
yes question right behind ya yes and
professors are accessible by emails oh
yes the question is are the TAS and
faculty members accessible by emails and
the answer is absolutely yes the faculty
members the courtiers on a request to
meet in person the answer is generally
yes I would say that faculty members are
really busy and depending upon the
numbers of students there's one course
for example last quarter that had 150
students and if everyone asked it
there's a sort of a time function
they're just hours in the day versus
students numbers but I would say that
generally speaking faculty and TAS will
accommodate a request to meet in person
that question right behind almost
certificated from a superkey head
towards the master's program masters so
the question and I'm gonna expand your
question a little bit so the question is
how does the certificate help expand or
allow for help you get two maybe two
toward graduate credit is that I got the
master's program so so right let me try
that again
so how does the certificate if you
complete a certificate will help you get
to to a master's degree maybe and allow
you access toward that master loop well
so I would say that if you do really
well
it could help that's what I would say in
when a non-aggression student applies he
or she is evaluated by the transcript
church transcript evaluation based on
some specific metrics at various by
department when you apply as a master's
degree student you're applying against
the pool that is accepted at Stanford
University and so they may be looking
for other things if your record in
having completed a certificate is really
good and the rest of the material that
comes through is also very good
including letters of recommendation
including preface because you're working
professionals the recommendation from
your boss and so on and the GREs scores
are excellent then the grades that you
achieve at Stanford University can't
hurt you especially if they're really
good but you need to understand that
you're competing against us pool of
candidates in any given year who may be
exceptionally great and so the
department has to make some tough
choices about their admissions processes
there are only so many slots per year
for each department so there's it
doesn't guarantee you a spot again it
can help you if you don't do well
certainly it can hurt you yes for 9zp at
SCPD and 3.9 GPA for the Stanford
graduates well so first I want to make
it clear that the question is what's
equivalent 3.94 SUV and 3.9 for Stanford
I want to make it clear that we as CPD
don't give grades so you're getting
graded by the Stanford faculty and the
Registrar holds the grades period full
stop there's no difference and there
should be different grades we stay out
of the grading business with a conduit
by which you can take courses access
those courses and and get data and and
in exchange with Stanford University so
yes you can apply for the part-time
masters in any given quarter like winter
quarter you can apply for a part-time
masters so the question is can you apply
at any time for for a master's degree so
the answer that questions generally no
there is one department which will allow
you quarter by quarter access Electrical
Engineering but other than that
Department are you interested in
electrical engineering okay so the good
news is that for you yes indeed you can
so yeah for electrical engineering we'll
all you quarter by quarter applications
most departments have their own policies
we encourage you to check their websites
about part time access the other thing
yes so the question is full-time
students are not allowed to to access so
what's what what gives
if Industry students well so I think of
this as a blessing you have a great
opportunity to take advantage of quarter
enrollment I think there's also
recognition that there was some
flexibility and built into electrical
engineering to try to accommodate
industry students and so they've chosen
to do that other departments don't want
to muddy the process they want to take
that evaluation on a year on annual
basis yes question back here
the question was can you replay lectures
and and the answer is absolutely yes you
can replay the lectures as many times as
you want in fact we encourage that you
can pause in in one iteration used to be
able to speed up and slow down like so
you could do one point three but I I
think that's gone away we're gonna try
to get that back though we understand
that that's a useful feature for some of
you so the question is can you apply for
a master's a midway through a
certificate course and still and still
carry your credits absolutely yes that
so so you can go through a certificate
you can be in process of applying and
still continue those credit units
through if you're accepted to the
master's degree program no problem
depending upon of course the
applications process and how that's
going you in the back yes so question
regarding the the time that we can watch
the the course videos so work hard to
enroll in the course to see if there's
specific time say for example 8:30 to
1945 yes for this for the course but
there's an anchor if that degree so
that's okay right so it's a great
question the question is on the website
there's a listing of the time specific
to the course that when it's offered
here on Stanford's campus actually the
good news is that doesn't matter for you
because most of you won't become
Stanford's campus in fact with your
non-degree option student you're not
really allowed technically the common
Stanford's campus but will off the
videos you can watch it anytime
typically an hour after the course is
completed so I'll give you a timestamp
of when that course is delivered
portions will be archived if you saw my
little demonstration you could scroll
down to week one I don't know if you
came in late but week one to in and all
those will be archived usually in
reverse order so that you're looking at
the most recent material yes can we
watch the last year's god videos can you
questions can we watch the last year's
archive videos and the answer's no it's
not that we don't wouldn't love to do
that but we're not we just from a server
perspective it would be onerous for us
and you know all this stuff so the
technical people tell me but many of you
are probably much more technically savvy
than I am
last question yes so the question is in
some cases you need to be on campus
because the faculty require it and in CS
145 Jennifer Widom absolutely requires
it the only way you can engage there is
if you show up on the Stanford campus
unfortunately but that's the faculty and
we honor the faculty request and it is
by the way a wonderful course and so we
encourage you if you want to enroll in
that course you should plan on coming to
Stanford's campus and planet plan
accordingly and with that I want to
thank you for your time and attention I
hope this has been helpful to give you
some perspective on the do's and don'ts
of the Stanford center for professional
development that you take graduate
courses from Stanford will be available
for questions there's a reception as
well and those should be subject experts
in a variety of different domains who
can answer questions for you about
various things and if you don't get your
question answered this evening you can
also click on the course advisors button
and ask us really tough questions that
gets us excited because we're helping
you and finally you get a chance to
network with colleagues from a variety
different companies and industries take
advantage of this time we hope this
begin
conversation not only with them but also
with us a lifelong journey through
education thank you so much and have a
good evening
you